guasta bye bye benvenuti su di pest
world che in italiano significa la
spalla profonda cioè io posso anche io
col mouse con la spada va bene no come
vecchie funzioni anno vsd per muoversi
ok che la spada con il tasto sinistro ok
è una cosa molto ambiguo bene il mouse a
ok la spada mi solleva anche va bene
l'on the dragon vive davanti drago che
si chiama drago il lungo va bene io ho
la spada lunga dalle porca [ __ ] giorno
dai il tuo miglior affondo affonda nel
suo cuore va bene ma la spada e piccola
ragazzi prima di darmi fuoco ha detto ma
il tema è già entrato io non posso fare
questo io ti ho portato indietro ho
fatto la tua strada più lunga più lunga
poi questo ragazzi è un po il dark souls
che non abbiamo chiesto ma che ci
meritiamo effettivamente 20 la più in
fondo questa volta va bene la caverna
sembra molto più profonda di prima ok
premier le peritore check point
anche perché si società ha quindi adesso
la difficoltà è anche arrivare al drago
va bene non ci passo c'è la spalla
troppo grossa e non è mai una cosa che
ho detto nella mia vita la smetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta
eccoci no no ragazzi ci fanno ci passa
di qua oddio non come come faccio a
passati scusatemi che questo vento
problemi non ci parlo non ci passa
all'aspetto no
oddio non solo fatto va bene salve
signor drager signora draghessa credo
che siano traghetti
dedicare dal dagli occhi se qua per
riprovarci let's go su questo c'è il
gatto che stava osservando gli fa il
solletico
ma dai ma dai ma grosso legge ho
allungato la sua spada ancora un
pochettino va bene stai attento al
baseball ragazzi ma che fischietti
indifferente chi ha pensato al suo gioco
che cazzo che cosa aveva in testa li
prego no voglio voglio sapere ho bisogno
di sapere questa cosa scusatemi ok no
ok aspetta è porca vacca devo fare il
suo giro e tv è un mezzo parkour ragazzi
e un paio diventato parkour è veramente
assurdo ma aspetta solo la madonna
ragazzi che cavaliere number one
let's go ciao tesoro perché la spada più
lunga aspetta che la spada e più lunga
questa è la parte di shrek che non hanno
fatto ed è quello quando ciuchino questa
volta ho sentito qualcosa si farà
l'abitare fuoco non mi dare fuoco ogni
volta mi spa esagerato sei quasi al
limite ragazzi stiamo arrivando
stiamo raggiungendo il trashume più
grande sono veramente curioso di leggere
il dialogo che arriverà tra un po r sarà
in parte che non possono anche dall
entrata stavolta ogni volta ragazzi che
gioca qualcosa mi sento in qualche modo
di dire che sono arrivato al momento più
alto della mia carriera ma
effettivamente questo lo è
cioè nel senso di che parliamo di cosa
parliamo
perfetto gargano stavate nuova
attenzione a questa nuova
addirittura mi fa fare un giro
dall'altra parte che casino ok let's go
madonna che pro gamer manco power power
non ci gioca di gioia
allora tesoro e ho visto su die in der
scritto che spada lunga che c'hai
sarebbe bello sentito lire di allora
aspettativa o molto profondo stavolta si
e sorpresa sorpresa
stavolta si torna questa è la spada
d'oro
questa è la spada più profonda che ha
detto lui è uno dei temi ha detto la
spada più profonda ha detto lui così
profonda ragazzi che cazzo se speriamo
che i miei genitori non vogliono
giampiero cosa sei montando ormai tanto
è tutto un doppio senso o gesù aspetta
quello che ha scritto sull'etichetta
perfetto perfetto madonna mi dico
ragazzine anche la zai under di mi sono
bloccato l'anno che neanche la sua
jandali tra di dark souls è veramente
così
c'è proprio qua stiamo arrivando a
livelli c'è stato sferici altro che
praise the sun place the dragon barbagia
in caso non diciamo cose o dio cosa c'è
scritto non lo so non sono inglese dove
posso passare di qua forse posso passare
in questa volta spetta spetta madonna mi
fa sempre parte di false per lavori che
ok no dai è bravissimo ciao
oddio no non solo di va come faccio con
aspetto aiuto come faccio passa roba no
non mi dire cosa di qua o santo di dio
mi sembra un po i soggetti mi sembra
mi sembra un po un esagerazione ragazzi
9 aspetta non ce la farò mai c'è qualche
problema di fondo non mi fido
non mi basta non mi basta non mi basta
c'è un prime di coach pixel in meno mi
si incastra la gamba perfettamente in
questo pixel attenzione proprio lui mica
come quei arrivo casa svedese sven
bender quest'anno sbagliato zeccardo ma
non è finita in stallo il gioco non che
sia installato perché
pesa tre mega però come faccio forse la
sopra su due ore ti prego gli ex cava o
non ci stiamo capendo una volta che
capisce come si fa ci metti un secondo
però quello il fatto che bisogna solo
capire la dinamica poi è stato facile
qua e non lo so però se madonna raga
pazzesco non è vero che non che non è
vero che caso per favore la donna che
casino donna porta gli è scappato ho
preso c'è poi come succede da allora c'è
point e è già un'ottima cosa ma donna
l'hanno fatta veramente difficile
l'ultima parte c'era anche un disastro
trovata ok
oddio se entrata se a drago ci ho messo
due ore per prepararmi ma ci sono con la
mia spada grossa aspetta un minuto
attenzione
dichiarazioni importanti aspetta un
minuto mi pesa troppo la spalla
d'attenzione gatto guarda questa è
[Musica]
io non posso veramente sacrosanto in dio
uk ma che cazzo giocherà uk in famiglia
ho salvato il gatto che ha appena detto
sei venuto per me va bene ti fest sword
il gioco dell'anno probabilmente non
saprei come commentare iori ci vediamo
al prossimo video lasciate un commento
mi piace anche ai vari social che come
una descrizione senso si richiede
esempio scegliamo al prossimo vito belle
ragazze
[Musica]